well welcome everybody it was quite a
long night with the State of the Union
delivered by Joe Biden it has led to
this cone of hair sticking out the side
of my head and sometimes it is even
stronger than gravity so I apologize to
the extent that it is distracting but we
have to talk about this Joe Biden State
of the Union my expectations were that
Joe Biden would probably mention a few
new policy ideas which he did but I did
not expect him to go at Republicans so
directly and so brutally and Republicans
are so easily triggered that the guess
was they would be somewhat triggered by
Joe Biden but the degree to which last
night's State of the Union Address made
these right Wingers explode even during
the event shouting things at Joe Biden
and humiliating themselves in so many
different ways it even surprised me now
Joe Biden called for a billionaire
attack
he called for a larger tax on stock
BuyBacks saying quadruple it presumably
from one to four percent he announced a
plan to expand the thirty five dollar a
month uh cost cap on insulin Beyond just
individuals on Medicare but what really
got them in a tizzy was when he really
laid an incredible trap for Republicans
where Joe Biden said you know some
Republicans want a sunset Social
Security and Medicare
and they started yelling no no no you're
a liar to which Joe Biden said well
great I guess that means that subject is
off the table and we don't even have to
talk about it anymore take a look at
this take the economy hostage I get it
unless I agree to their economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share of some Republicans
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset I'm not saying
it's a majority
laughs
anybody
back my office
give you a copy and there you see
Marjorie Taylor green very much
channeling Cruella Deville screaming and
pointing at Joe Biden the copy of The
Proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see you now I tell you
I enjoy conversion
you know how amazing
this doesn't keep the programs the way
they are they'd go away other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look folks
the idea is
that we're not going to be we're not
going to be moved into being threatened
to default on the debt if we don't
respond
folks
as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now
[Applause]
so listen this is this is really one of
the greatest traps that I've seen set in
this sort of live format it would be a
good trap no matter what but to carry it
out live in front of an audience is is
quite stunning now it is a subject of
debate whether Republicans really are
open to Sun setting Social Security and
Medicare the idea of sun setting is
something that was popularized by Rick
Scott senator from Florida
which is all legislation sunsets after
five years and then we decide do we want
to bring it back or not and he didn't
name Social Security and Medicare but he
also didn't say Social Security and
Medicare were exempt so a reasonable
interpretation would be they are open to
sunsetting Social Security and Medicare
although maybe their intention is to
keep them as they are but debate aside
Republicans flipping out in this way now
puts them in a corner where they can't
seriously they can't in a serious manner
come forward and say well let's debate
whether we want to cut Social Security
and Medicare because here they seemed
vehement in their opposition to that so
an absolutely brilliant trap really a
master class in exposing these
Hypocrites and the event also exposed by
the way that Kevin McCarthy has no power
Kevin McCarthy trying to shush members
who were screaming during the State of
the Union Address they ignored him uh
here is one moment during which Marjorie
Taylor green screams out and if you're
watching you will see Kevin McCarthy
shaking his head no and trying to shush
her with very little success invest in
American innovation and Industry will
Define the future that China intends to
be dominated
investing in our alliances and there you
see McCarthy shake his head and go shhh
and he had no control no control over
his party uh here is just one of many
images of Marjorie Taylor green just
screaming at the top of her lungs and
completely humiliating herself in every
way when the topic of fentanyl came up
which is increasingly being pronounced
fentanyl I still don't know why they
pronounce it this way but in any case
you know what what I'm talking about
when Joe Biden brought up the deaths as
a result of Fentanyl
um a Heckler believed to be Matt Gates
started screaming it's your fault it's
your fault and this was another
opportunity for Republicans to debase
themselves fentanyl is killing more than
70 000 Americans a year
[Music]
[Applause]
you got it
so you hear combinations of it's your
fault it's the Border Etc the idea being
that weak On the Border Joe Biden is
letting fentanyl in now of course as
we've been covering since Joe Biden
became president the differences in
Border policy between Donald Trump and
Joe Biden are extraordinarily subtle
really the change is that as the
pandemic eased movement of people
increased again but this is another one
of these baseless tropes there were all
of the standard sort of uh elements of
Pomp and Circumstance during the State
of the Union uh one of the moments was
when
um Joe Biden actually
um recognized I guess we would say
Brandon say the 26 year old who disarmed
the Monterey Park gunman and these
moments are common in state of the union
addresses join us tonight is Brandon
saying a 26 year old hero Brandon put
his college green games on hold to be at
his mom's side his mom's side when she
was dying from cancer
Brandon
Brandon now works at the dance studio
started by his grandparents
two weeks ago
during the Lunar New Year celebrations
he heard the studio door closed and you
saw a man standing there pointing
semi-automatic pistol atom
he thought he was going to die
but he thought about the people inside
and that instant he found the courage to
act and Wrestled a semi-automatic pistol
away from the gunman who had already
killed 11 people in another Dance Studio
11.
he saved lives
it's time we do the same
band assault weapons now
[Music]
and there is Lauren bobert of course
shaking her head probably upset that
Brandon say wasn't armed himself in
order to stop that gunman
um another Moment Like This Joe Biden
recognizing Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul
Pelosi of course who was attacked
brutally and viciously uh by a
what do we even call call the guy a
radicalized conspiracy theorist of sorts
and it is actually really good to see
that 82 year old Paul Pelosi uh seems to
be recovering well two years our
democracy has been threatened and
attacked put at risk
put to the test in his Very Room on
January the 6th
and then just a few months ago
an unhinged big lie
a sale and Unleashed a political
violence the home of the Dead Speaker of
the House Representatives
using the very same language the
insurrectionists used as they stalk
these halls and chanted on January 6th
here tonight in this chamber is a man
who Bears the scars of that brutal
attack
but is as tough and as strong as
resilient as they get my friend Paul
Pelosi Paul Stanley
and of course these are calculated
moments these are stage managed moments
but they are moments that are expected
and then of course as is often the case
because presidents want to make the case
that things are good under their
stewardship Joe Biden closing the
evening with pretty strong optimism
we're not powerless before the forces to
confront us
it's within our power of We the People
we're facing the test of our time
we have to be the nation we've always
been at our best optimistic hopeful
forward-looking a nation that braces a
light over dark
hope over fear Universal stability over
chaos and it went on from there so a
good speech overall the three real
proposals billionaire attacks increasing
the tax on stock BuyBacks and expanding
the 35 a month price cap on insulin many
other topics discussed Republicans
extraordinarily triggered and leading to
maybe the most disgusting State of the
Union response speech which I want to
talk about next Sarah Huckabee Sanders
the Republican governor of Arkansas was
selected to deliver the response to Joe
Biden's State of the Union Address last
night maybe the most disgusting and
delusional State of the Union response
that I have ever seen and by the way
being given by someone whose state is a
disaster now it's not an ad hominem when
I say Arkansas is a disaster it is uh
empirically a disaster it is the seventh
worst state in the country
in terms of places to raise a family
45th for health and safety in the five
worst states for violent crime per
capita 47th in infant mortality 41st in
education 41st in the economy the state
is a disaster and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is spending time and resources on things
like for example Banning the teaching of
critical race theory in Arkansas Public
Schools which wasn't being taught anyway
and she is selected to deliver the
response okay we knew it would be a big
anti-woke party and indeed Sarah
Huckabee Sanders starts her response
speech basically by calling Biden a liar
and she knows a lot about lying that's
for sure she was Trump's press secretary
for a while three
good evening I'm Sarah Huckabee Sanders
we know being a mom to three young
children
taught me not to believe every story I
hear
so forgive me for not believing much of
anything I heard tonight from President
Biden from out of control inflation and
violent crime remember violent crime
trending down inflation down six months
in a row to the dangerous border crisis
and threat from China remember that
nothing has substantively changed with
border policy from Trump to Biden the
China thing is sort of like an amorphous
one
Biden and the Democrats have failed you
they know it and you know it nothing
really factual there but an interesting
way to start she then goes really hard
into the woke stuff claiming listen we
got sucked into this culture where we
didn't want it which is quite a bit of
revisionist history and while you read
the consequences of their failures the
Biden Administration seems more
interested in woke fantasies than the
hard reality Americans face every day
most Americans simply want to live their
lives in Freedom and peace
but we are under attack in a left-wing
culture War we didn't start and never
wanted to fight hard to imagine a bigger
lie than that Republicans realizing they
were failing on policy and that the
country was turning on them on just
about every issue decided we are no
longer going to fight for policy we're
just going to fight the culture War this
is quite literally the opposite of the
truth every day we are told we must
partake in their rituals salute their
flags and worship their false Idols all
while big government colludes with big
Tech to strip away the most American
thing there is ah your freedom of speech
another dog whistle that they use
endlessly to point the finger at all
sorts of different parties over people's
supposed speech being taken away when it
is not now Sarah Huckabee Sanders did
say one thing I agree with she meant it
differently but she said that the
dividing line is now between normal and
crazy I agree with that I disagree with
her about which side is crazy the
dividing line in America is no longer
between bride or left
the choice is between normal
or crazy true it's time for a new
generation of Republican leadership
upon taking office just a few weeks ago
I signed executive orders to ban CRT
racism and indoctrination in our schools
now remember CRT is not being taught in
Arkansas schools however Arkansas is
still at the bottom of the list in terms
of Education out of 50 States but that's
how she chose to use her time as
governor and resources
um let's go to the very end of this
disgusting speech Sarah Huckabee Sanders
ending it with a painful looking Grimace
look at this thank you God bless you and
God bless America
yeah
um
following the theme of the Republican
party for the last six eight ten twelve
years
absolutely no meaningful substantive
policy for just everyday people who work
or who want to work or who used to work
but became disabled or whatever it's
it's none of that just culture War
dog whistles
anti-wokeness and a focus on issues that
aren't even really issues and of course
completely straw Manning the totality of
Joe Biden's speech maybe the most vile
State of the Union response that I have
ever seen from an individual who is
quite frankly one of the most vile
participants in American politics that I
can recall over the last 10 to 20 years
maybe my favorite moment from the entire
State of the Union yesterday was
when Senator Mitt Romney a republican
had a conversation with lying Republican
Congressman George Santos it was
seemingly tense after the fact Mitt
Romney was asked what was that all about
and Romney says I told Santos you don't
belong here Romney listen not not a guy
I voted for in 2012 but uh
good for him for saying this to George
Santos check this out
yeah
I didn't expect that he'd be standing
there trying to shake hands with every
senator in the president United States
that's the guy given given the fact that
he's under ethics investigation he
should be sitting in the back road
staying quiet uh
parading in front of the president and
uh and and people coming into the room
by the way I have to tell you many
elected officials in these situations
they walk super fast and it makes the
reporters have to Sprint and blah blah
blah look at Romney respectfully walking
slowly in order to allow the reporters
to do their job you got to commend the
guy for it he said he says he you know
that he embellished his record look
embellishing is saying you've got an A
when you get an A minus is saying you
graduated from a college you didn't even
attend and you shouldn't be in Congress
and uh they're going to go through the
process and hopefully get them out and
uh but he shouldn't be there and if he
had any shame at all he wouldn't be
there right why did you make a point to
say that though I mean I mean it was
kind of out of your way he was standing
right there in the aisle shaking hands
with everybody did he respond to you uh
he may have I didn't hear it
man this is just absolutely the best and
John Boy did a sort of attempt at lip
reading what went on let's just listen
to a little bit of it I would have given
a lot to be sitting right there between
the two of these guys my Twitter just
absolutely blew up from this lip reading
so I'll try and dive into it a little
bit you everyone's kind of figured out
what what Romney is saying he comes in
on the bottom right he says you ought to
be embarrassed
you ought to be embarrassed
ought to be embarrassed you got to be
embarrassed you got to be it's saying
you got to be embarrassed and he's just
saying I should be
I should be
and then I don't know what he says here
I actually don't know what Romney says
because it looks like
that looks anyway so then they go back
and forth fourth looking at this like
it's the Zapruder film good for Mitt
Romney I don't have much other
commentary other than good for Mitt
Romney we've got to keep the pressure up
on George Anthony Santos de volder some
people wrote to me and said you
shouldn't include Katara because there's
really nothing lying about being a drag
queen although he did lie about whether
he was a drag queen but you maybe don't
include Katara so anyway George Anthony
devolder Santos he shouldn't be there
and we've got to keep the pressure up so
that uh he maybe will resign I I think
the the window may be closing on that
but absolutely nice job by Mitt Romney
so big picture Joe Biden good speech uh
triggering Republicans overtly Sarah
Huckabee Sanders disgusting response and
Mitt Romney best sort of uh uh I guess
we would call it ancillary moment
um at the event and we will have all of
these clips for you on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and on our YouTube
channel at youtube.com slash the David
Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the Republican primary battle between
failed former president Donald Trump and
current Republican governor of Florida
Ron DeSantis hasn't even started yet and
it is already getting towards
allegations of pedophilia I know that it
sounds crazy but failed former president
Donald Trump has gone very very low
suggesting that Ron DeSantis might be a
pedophile in a new attack in which he
accuses DeSantis of grooming young girls
this is really something else Business
Insider has a story about it Trump
shares photos of DeSantis alleging he
partied and drank with high school girls
when he was a teacher Trump re-shared a
20 year old photo of DeSantis that
appears to show imposing with recent
high school graduates the original
poster accused DeSantis of using alcohol
for quote grooming high school girls
Trump is ramping up attacks against the
Florida governor who May challenge him
May challenge him for the 2024 GOP
nominee here is the post Donald Trump
posting yesterday that's not Ron is it
he would never do such a thing and
indeed it is an image
shared by a different truth social user
truth essential with a picture of an
individual that appears to be Ron
DeSantis
three women whose faces are blurred and
the title here is Ron Des sanctimonious
grooming high school girls with alcohol
as a teacher now you don't have to
defend Ron desantis's actions to realize
how ugly this has the potential to get
now there's a few different stories here
one story is if Trump is going this hard
against a guy who isn't even running
against him yet how ugly would an actual
campaign get between DeSantis and Trump
I think the answer is it would get
extraordinarily ugly potentially more
than ugly enough to damage both of them
and help whoever is the Democratic
candidate and that's something I would
be very glad to see secondly there is
this question of hypocrisy because at
the end of the day remember when Donald
Trump ran Miss Teen USA and Miss us say
he said I'll go backstage before a Show
everybody's getting dressed you know no
men anywhere but I'm allowed to go in
because I'm the owner of the pageant so
I'm inspecting it you know they're
standing there with no clothes these
incredible looking women and I get away
with things like that so Trump doesn't
exactly have an unblemished record with
this stuff grab them by the you know
what the allegations by E Gene Carroll
the allegations which were later uh
retracted in the legal sense against
Trump
um and Jeffrey Epstein together
involving a young girl you know there's
all these different things so there's
the hypocrisy angle as well but at this
point it is abundantly clear if DeSantis
runs against trump it may be the ugliest
Republican primary I don't want to say
ever because there have been some ugly
things in history but certainly the
ugliest in the modern media era of the
last four 40 years and uh it's I don't
think it's good for the country to see
it but at the same time if it hurts both
Trump and DeSantis in the long run it is
actually good for the country DeSantis
or Trump being president next
would be so bad for the country
that anything that damages or reduces
that possibility is actually a good
thing for the country so it's getting
very ugly very quickly and it's only
going to get worse I want to show you a
very funny short clip of Republican
senator Marco Rubio Rubio appeared on
Fox news last night after Joe Biden's
State of the Union Address
and it is so funny what Rubio says I'm
not even going to tease it for you okay
let's just play it and then we will
discuss you didn't hear a lot of talk
about pregnant men tonight you didn't
hear a lot of talk about some of these
crazy things because they're pivoting
now to an election mode and they know
all that stuff is toxic so try and
pretend it's not happening but it
remains at the core and at the heart of
their Administration not a lot of woke
talk tonight except for the climate
stuff which by the way he doesn't tell
you benefits China
Marco Rubio realizing in real time Joe
Biden didn't talk about pregnant men Joe
Biden didn't talk about woke stuff
he says it's because they're pivoting to
election mode the reality is Joe Biden
never was talking about this stuff and
in fact these are very small issues on
the Democratic side on the left in the
Democratic party I will not deny for a
second
that if you spend a lot of time on
Twitter or Reddit you might see a whole
bunch of stuff about
wokeness and so-called pregnant men and
all of these things I don't deny that
you might see that if you spend a lot of
time on these platforms but if you spend
a lot of time on those on those
platforms you would have been one of the
people in 2020 who thought that Bernie
had the nomination wrapped up and that
there was no interest in Joe Biden being
the nominee and as I told you then as
and as I will repeat now
the discussions that dominate some of
these online spheres are not actually
the issues of Greater concern to the
vast majority of the democratic party
nor of the constituents of the
democratic party either and there was a
reason that you didn't hear a lot about
woke uh sorry about pregnant men last
night which is it's not actually an
issue that is at the Forefront of the
minds of almost anyone on the left I
would actually go even further
part of the reason that those sorts of
things even come up at all are because
the right has abandoned policy and only
wants to talk about that sort of thing
it is because the right brings forward
issues of they're putting cat litter
boxes for furries who are studio for
people who think they're animals are
they even know how to define furry
um but that's not a real story but it is
the right that creates the story it's
the writer who says they want double
mastectomies for prepubescent girls wait
a second
do they have breasts if they're
prepubescent that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever it's the right that is
crowbarring a lot of these issues in
none of this stuff has ever been at the
heart of the democratic party and this
is why looking at Twitter
isn't super useful to figure out what's
going on in the US overall and what's
going on within the Democratic party
maybe Marco Rubio is realizing that if
you want to see this clip it's on our
YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's a
great pleasure to be joined Today by
George mombio who is a best-selling
author Guardian columnist environmental
activist and whose latest book is
Regenesis feeding the world without
devouring the planet it's really great
to have you on and you know this is a
conversation that could start in any
number of points but but maybe let's
start it this way I think many of us now
realize intuitively that planning on
indefinite growth on a on a planet of
limited resources mathematically makes
little sense there's something that we
recognize there intuitively however
there are various perspectives as to
what the sort of real big issue is
whether it is transportation emissions
fossil fuels eating meat whatever the
case may be what's the best way to frame
the problem to be solved and what is the
most sensible approach to solving that
problem
so so the the problem is the Gathering
collapse of Earth Systems it's not a
climate problem it's not a soil problem
it's not a forest problem it's not a
fish problem it's not a transport
problem it's it's not an anything else
problem it's an everything problem it's
all Earth Systems together are suffering
massive strain as a result of human
activity
and these are our life support systems
these are what sustain this remarkable
beautiful diverse abundant planet on
which we are so lucky to live
and all these Earth Systems are complex
systems which means it means a very
specific thing they're self-organizing
and they're self-stabilizing within a
range of stress but you push them beyond
that range and the self-organizing
properties become self-amplifying
and they then amplify shocks passing
across the network until the point when
they hit their critical threshold
and collapse into a different
equilibrium State can you give out and a
couple of examples of that because it
may in the abstract it may not be
obvious what that means
well a classic example was the great
Dust Bowl which you in in North America
will be well familiar with in fact it's
one of many dust bowls that have
happened over history but it's the one
that everyone knows about
and soil is a complex system it's a
fascinating extraordinary ecosystem from
which we get 99 of our calories
but if you hit it and hit it and hit it
repeatedly with bad plowing with other
bad decisions in agriculture then you
degrade it and degrade it and you might
not notice very much to begin with
you'll notice perhaps a slight drop off
in crop yield a few other issues taking
place but it's still there still seems
to be functioning okay but what's
happened is that unbeknown to you it has
lost its resilience and then an external
shock comes along like a major drought
and instead of damping down that shock
and regulating itself as a healthy
system does this degraded system
amplifies that shot and suddenly
collapses and the rate of erosion of
soil erosion when when it's highly
degraded and hit by a major drought can
rise 6 000 fold more or less overnight
it just falls off a cliff and then the
soil which stays on the land because
it's a biological structure like a coral
reef it's built by the little creatures
that live in it
um because that biological function has
collapsed the structure completely
collapses and then it can literally blow
away it can just blow away in the wind
or wash away with the rain and suddenly
there's no soil on the land and that's
what happened in the great Dust Bowl
many other dust bowls but it's what
happens in different ways to every kind
of complex system another one which very
nearly collapsed was the financial
system in 2008 and again very similar
reasons it it behaves in enormous
identical fashion bizarrely and it's
self-organizing without human agency
obviously there's human agency involved
but the human agency doesn't control the
structural Dynamics within that system
and it came within a whisker of collapse
and it was only a bailout globally
amounting to trillions of dollars that
prevented that complete collapse into a
new equilibrium state which would have
been very hard indeed to come come back
from
speaking of of equilibrium States I'm
curious your thoughts to pick one area
that you've written about and that is a
big subject of discussion you know when
we talk about for example our food
system there are a number of different
perspectives about what particular
aspect of it is problematic and sort of
individual as well as collective
decisions that can and arguably should
be made one perspective is well it's
really about which foods are being eaten
and for example if we went off
completely of animal Agriculture and
replace protein with you know this is
not groundbreaking stuff here right
we're talking about soy and almond and
all these different things then we
things we would just be much better off
and then the counter to that has been
well you know
almond and avocado extraordinarily water
intensive they're transporting bees to
the west coast of the U.S half the bees
die so by number of organisms you're
doing damage in a different way what
about the idea of a regenerative type of
Agriculture Which is less about do we
include animal products or not but using
land in a different way and there's some
interesting pilot projects of this being
done in the United States and the
counter to that becomes well that's
really lovely for I forget the guy's
name in Virginia who's doing it but
that's not that useful if you're then
transporting that food across the
country or it would have so it becomes
really difficult for the quote average
person to really know what should I do
and what should we do as a society how
do we parse some of these discussions
yeah no well these are all the right
questions the first thing is that the
term regenerative has become a bit like
the term sustainable it's slapped in
front of anything you happen already to
be doing so regenerative ranching
formerly known as ranching all right and
um it's and it's all I mean it hasn't
been used for very long but it's already
completely lost its meaning and everyone
says oh well yes of course what I'm
doing is regenerative and you say Okay
regenerative of what why are you
regenerating here
so in in some parts of the US and and
certainly where I live in the United
Kingdom if it's to be ecologically
regenerative one of the absolute
Baseline
um uh conditions for that is that trees
can return to a formerly forested land
if if there were once trees on your land
and the trees are not coming back that
is not an ecologically regenerative
system that's a really really basic
measure of whether it's ecologically
regenerative or not and of course
agricultural systems you know they don't
let trees come back spontaneously
because you know either you're plowing
the land or you're grazing animals which
selectively browse out tree seedlings
because they're very tasty and
nutritious so so that's not going to
happen so ecologically it doesn't even
meet the most basic the crudest measure
of what regenerative means
in terms of keeping soil on the land
there's no doubt that some systems are
better at doing that than others but
against it you must weigh how much are
they producing so so what you've got to
measure against this idea of how well
it's protecting the soil is is also how
much it's producing so if you've got a
very extensive system occupying a huge
amount of land not doing very much
damage to the soil but not producing
very much either that can be just as
damaging in all sorts of other ways as a
very intensive system which is doing
more damage to the soil but producing
lots of food and the reason for that is
the massive ecological opportunity costs
and carbon opportunity costs of
extensive farming what that means is
that every hectare or every acre of land
that you're using could have been
supporting a wild ecosystem if you
weren't using it it could have been
supporting a forest or a natural
grassland or a Savannah or Wetland all
of which are crucial ecosystems and the
great majority of the world species
depend on wild ecosystems for their
survival so a lot of what's called
regenerative is just actually extensive
it's low yield farming occupying a lot
of land and that's agricultural sprawl
and just like urban sprawl agricultural
sprawl is a very bad thing we should be
leaving as much land as we possibly can
for nature so the Holy Grail what we
really need to look for
is farming which has high yield and low
impact and that's a really hard thing to
achieve a few farmers are managing to do
that and and we should celebrate that
and find ways of replicating what
they're doing but we shouldn't be
celebrating either high yield and high
impact or low yield and low impact let
alone in some cases particularly
ranching low yield and high impact
that's a very worst kind of system and
unfortunately the great majority of
cattle and sheep ranching ticks that box
low yield high impact they kill the
large Predators they exclude the trees
they exclude the wild herbivores it's an
ecological disaster
so Joel Saladin at polyface farms was
was the guy I was thinking of earlier
and so there are these different ideas
that include uh micro bike microbial
proteins insect protein a shift to
Perennial crops vertical farming uh
Slash indoor farming slash Urban farming
which are sort of overlapping ideas do
any of those get this idea of high yield
and low impact some do some don't some
are much more successful than others and
you know there's a lot of nonsense in
this field you have to really carefully
pass you know what where's the nonsense
where's where's a good common sense
um the one that um hits the button most
effectively is precision fermentation
growing food from microbes so for 12 000
years we've been using multicellular
organisms animals and plants to produce
our food and we've been breeding them
and breeding them and pushing them to
their very limits and Beyond you know if
you go into an intensive chicken farm or
hog farm you'll see animals push beyond
their their limits but we've scarcely
begun with single-celled organisms and
these are super productive and use far
less in terms of land in terms of water
in terms of fertilizer and other
environmental resources you can produce
according to one set of estimates I did
all the world's protein on an area of
land the size of greater London are
capital city in the UK all the world's
protein and that then would enable you
to release huge tracts of land for
ecological restoration that's genuine
regeneration bringing back ecosystems
that we've destroyed what sort of food
item would it be that one is consuming
in that in that estimate so
um what it produces is a high protein
flour about 60 protein that you can turn
into almost anything so um I had it in
its raw State I was the first person in
the world outside the laboratory staff
to eat a pancake made of of microbial
flour
um did it taste like chicken
surprisingly as they say
actually bizarrely it tasted like a
pancake okay
it was a small flip for men and um the
um and but you know that was just simply
taking the the flower yeah made from the
the dead bodies of these bacteria
um turning it uh mixing it with a bit of
wheat flour because the protein content
was too high otherwise you would have
made an omelette
um um and then a bit of water and bang
you you've got a pancake but then it
because these proteins are much closer
to animal proteins and plant proteins
are you can produce animal like products
much more more easily much more
effectively far less processing
tastier cheaper than a whole lot but you
can do all sorts of other things as well
and just like the Agricultural
Revolution produced a whole load of
products that people couldn't even
imagine I mean when the first people
caught a wild cow they weren't thinking
of Camembert right
um so the the microbial Revolution will
produce Endless Possibilities that we
can't even picture at this time all
sorts of new tastes and textures and
flavors the last thing I want to ask you
about zooms out a little bit you know
when there was this in many cities and
states in the United States the plastic
straw debate as we might call it about
individual restaurants saying we're
going to have paper straws or we will
use a pasta noodle as a straw you know
these different things there was a
blowback which said you know those
individual decisions are fine but really
they they are almost a way not to think
about where the vast emissions come from
which is industry history where is the
balance between individual choices
versus focusing on the type of activism
that will make systemic change if we
think about all the way over on the
individual side all the way over on the
activism only side where is there a
balance to be found that's most
effective
well what economic power and political
power wants us to to do is to think of
ourselves as consumers
yeah and say oh we can make decisions
you know we as consumers we can change
things through the things that we buy
and our power as consumers is always
weak partly because there are some super
consumers and mega consumers we call
them billionaires and they have far more
power than we do and we've got
absolutely no means of influencing them
and then there's multi-millionaires who
also have far more power than we do and
so so you know we're really weak as
consumers and our choices are really
limited anyway and generally the
difference between them is absolutely
microscopic except for issues like
whether you eat animal products or not
you know cutting out animal products
from your diet that makes a huge
difference the way you travel the way
you heat your home those are important
things most of the rest is pretty minor
consume less yeah but consume
differently you don't make that much of
a difference
but as Citizens we are powerful and
demanding new systems changes to systems
that's where our power comes in and of
course you know we're just constantly
discouraged from seeing ourselves that
way precisely because when we see
ourselves that way we become a threat to
existing power structures and when it
comes to something like the world food
system which is coming under tremendous
pressure and great threat we have to
mobilize and become active politically
if we're going to intervene effectively
in it
absolute last thing with the new
estimates that global population is
actually going to Peak and start to
decline at some point this century
does that do anything to counteract all
of the estimates that assume continued
population growth Beyond 2050 or 2070
whenever the estimate is does that
actually say Hey you know we actually
don't need to be quite as worried about
some of these things as some are
well so human population growth is about
the only environmental indicator which
is plateauing okay almost all the others
are going through the ceiling
um and it's weird how some people still
go on and on about population growth oh
it's population and that's a way really
of deflecting responsibility because we
you know living in the rich World
consuming far more than the average
global citizen we can then point to to
people much poorer than ourselves
probably brown people black people and
say they're the problem they're the
problem because they're having too many
babies it's a way of deflecting blame
and responsibility
but there is a genuine population crisis
it's a livestock population crisis
because while the human population
growth has come down to below one
percent a year yes a massive decline
livestock population is growing at 2.4
percent a year that's a massive rate of
growth and to put it in crude terms by
2050 there'll be an extra 100 million
tons of human being on the planet and an
extra 400 million tons of livestock on
the planet right they are consuming the
planet it is it is our livestock eating
habits which are driving us to Global
catastrophe above anything else so yeah
there is a population crisis but it's
not the one people are talking about
the book is Regenesis feeding the world
without devouring the planet we've been
speaking with the book's Author George
mombio really appreciate your time today
very much
thanks David great to talk to you
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
many of you a few days ago sent me video
of What appears to be Marjorie Taylor
green serving as Speaker of the House of
Representatives telling me that it made
you physically ill to see it
interestingly that is exactly the
headline that Newsweek selected for
their coverage of this bizarre event
called Marjorie Taylor green presiding
over house leaves viewers quote
physically ill now I want to make sure
everybody knows what did and did not
happen let's take a look at the video of
Marjorie Taylor green and then I will
tell you what this was all about
pursuant to the rule the gentleman from
Arkansas Mr Westerman and the gentleman
gentlewoman from New Mexico Miss Miss
Fernandez each will control 20 minutes
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
Arkansas now many of you saw that and
wrote to me and said David is Marjorie
Taylor green now the speaker of the
house she is not the Speaker of the
House what you have to understand is
that she briefly presided over the house
this is a role called speaker pro
tempore or sort of means like for a
little while and it's frequently rotated
it doesn't give you you are not the
Speaker of the House you were
temporarily presiding but it is simply a
um it's a duty we could say it's an
assignment that you can be given and she
was not the speaker of the house that
being said it is disgusting and very
worrying that someone has unhinged as
Marjorie Taylor green is slowly pulling
herself closer to the mainstream of the
Republican Party a mainstream by the way
which is outrageously extreme it's a
mainstream that has become extreme there
was a segment on CNN about this let's
take a look at a little bit of a margin
Taylor green the Republican
congresswoman from Georgia re-elected in
November she has pushed baseless Q Anon
lies and conspiracies that include
saying that Democrats and celebrities
are part of a Satan worshiping pedophile
ring she has since tried to walk back
her involvement in Q Anon she also
questioned the events of 9 11 something
she's also tried to walk back
the so-called plane that crashed into
the Pentagon it's odd there's never any
evidence shown for a plane in the
Pentagon there is an Islamic Invasion
into our government offices right now
Kennedy getting killed in the plane
crash that's another one of those
um Clinton murders right so she has
pushed conspiracy that mass shootings
were staged and false listen you get the
point it is outrageous that someone who
has said the things Marjorie Taylor
green has said even got herself elected
okay but she did voters in Georgia
wanted her to represent them or at least
they thought they did but it is a new
level of absurdity that there is this
image even if it is only a very
temporary role a speaker pro tempore uh
presiding over the House of
Representatives I'm with you I'm with
you and the world sees it and they are
horrified how is it that in the United
States such a deranged individual can
achieve this level of power and
prominence and of course if you remember
what happened in 2016 with Donald Trump
the Marjorie Taylor green Fiasco all of
a sudden seems a lot less unlikely but
there it was we will almost certainly
see it again over the next couple of
years and then hopefully never again
after that I am going to show you the
cycle the mechanism of how the mind
virus spreads through people like Tucker
Carlson this is I really hope that this
is instructive for people okay this was
a cycle that took place over the last
week or so
um an article was written in Newsweek by
a student okay an individual named Kevin
bass wrote an article in Newsweek which
got a bunch of attention called it's
time for the scientific Community to
admit we were wrong about covid and it
cost lives and as you can see
uh the title for Kevin bass is Ms
mdphd student medical school and he
wrote an article where he says as a
medical student and researcher I saw
staunchly supported efforts when it came
to covid but then he comes to say we
were wrong we were wrong about
everything now this is an opinion piece
by somebody who is not really strictly
speaking an authority on any of this
stuff we're talking about a student here
and students know things okay no
disrespect to students but the idea that
this is some kind of medical Authority
is of course very very wrong the fact
that this article was written
got Kevin bass an interview on Tucker
Carlson the next day or a few days later
the fact that he was on Tucker then
makes it seem as if this guy really is a
medical professional rather than just a
guy with an opinion in Newsweek and of
course when something appears on Tucker
Carlson even though Tucker's show is an
opinion show then it is repeated
elsewhere as if it is news and very
often the next day Fox and Friends will
say as discussed by Tucker Carlson
yesterday and this is how you take
nothing you take an opinion article by a
student who's not a medical Authority in
Newsweek and turn it into what seems
like wow it's a report that we were
wrong about covid so let's take a look
at a little bit of this interview with
uh Tucker and Kevin best
thank you for coming on and thank you
for writing this piece which I thank you
I want to recommend everyone totally
non-political again I don't even know
what your politics are I assume you're
liberal but you're honest in this piece
why were you moved to write this this
man is not a doctor or a scientist or a
nurse or a health care worker he's never
seen a patient
he's a he's a student Tucker Carlson has
a student on a show to talk about an
editorial that he wrote
let's hear some of his words shall we
this is by the way from the uh Twitter
account decoding Fox News which is a
really good account
many of the reasons that you discussed
that I realized that we have lost trust
in this country as a healthcare industry
from the the ordinary person uh anybody
who knows anybody who's watching the
media anybody who is on social media and
is talking to Ordinary People realizes
just how angry so many Ordinary People
are and I thought who the heck is an
ordinary person
if you're not a healthcare worker you're
just a student you're calling other
people ordinary I'm a little confused
here I thought that if I wrote a piece
like this apologizing for
you know I didn't set policy but I
certainly supported it and every single
day I certainly added all my friends on
the back for supporting it and for for
for thinking the right kinds of thoughts
I dude you're just a dude who wrote an
opinion piece
that's it you
you've they're not a doctor I thought if
I apologized then at least I was doing
my part
um to to to make things better and what
an attention grab I mean genuinely what
an attention grab this nonsense is and
if you look at the article again this is
just a guy with some opinions he talks
about how he believes scientific
expertise wasn't used appropriately how
a lot of things were preferences and not
really science it became a team sport
there were obfuscations about aerosol
spread and transmission and mass
mandates and all these different things
and he is ready to admit it and of
course that is ripe it is ripe for a
propagandist like Tucker Carlson to say
this sounds great for our show come on
in come on in and explain yourself and
the Fox News viewer doesn't really know
any better medical researcher oh wow
we're talking about a student who is not
a medical Authority in any way who just
said in an opinion piece I used to think
things that I believe were wrong
that's all it is not substantively
relevant to anything but this is exactly
the type of propaganda that many Fox
News viewers see and go oh you know what
it's true The Masks don't work and the
vaccine doesn't work and it never made
sense to stay home and this thing
doesn't spread and it's not a
respiratory virus and it came from a
Chinese lab and all these different
things whereas not only is this guy not
even saying that he's not even someone
with any actual uh medical authority to
be making these claims and this is how
they create a feedback loop we've seen
it in so many other ways the Fox News
opinion side gives an opinion it is then
reported on by the news side as if it is
newsworthy that such an opinion was
given here we're just adding an
additional layer a guy writes an opinion
opinion show Tucker Carlson invites the
guy as if he's an authority to give that
opinion
and then it spreads even further as if
it is now news that this guy said we got
a bunch of stuff wrong about covet now
were there things that as we got more
information our views changed of course
were there things where the facts
changed over time
of course early the first vaccine was
very effective at preventing
transmission against the original
variant of covid over time that
effectiveness at preventing transmission
dropped to what I most recently
understand to be essentially no
protection the idea being that the
vaccine is very effective at reducing
serious illness hospitalization and
death so as the facts changed what I
made an effort to report to you based on
those facts also change but it was never
about my opinions this is just opinion
this is how Fox News turns it into quote
news reporting let's talk a little bit
about we are just asking questions we
are just asking questions I'm going to
play you a clip from CNN of James Comer
being interviewed by Caitlin Collins
and confronted about a conspiracy theory
he floated about the Chinese balloon
take a look at this one thing you said
as we were learning about this balloon
when tracking it you
ads in that balloon did that balloon
take out from Wuhan we don't know
anything about it but you don't have any
evidence that this guy I asked a
question I mean what is in the balloon
this is something that we believe the
the White House should have uh advise us
on they should have had a briefing to
tell us what this was I mean back home
in Kentucky this is all anybody talks
about what was this book everyone was
concerned in Kentucky it was all balloon
24 7. yeah no one trusts China they know
China is an adversary my concern was the
military had no idea anything about the
balloon what was in the balloon uh where
was it a spy balloon was it a weather
balloon like China said what exactly did
the did the U.S military know about this
what did our intelligence know about
this did they know it was even in
airspace before it got in the Alaska
airspace so you know it's just a lot of
questions and that was just one of the
questions just for all we know it could
have bile weapons in it they could be
testing
no no I didn't I asked a question he's
just asking questions sort of like I
could say is James Comer a pedophile
bank robber who secretly spends his time
producing child porn why hasn't anyone
investigated Why Won't Anyone
investigate it well be David because
there's no evidence of that I'm just
asking questions as a phrase has become
a really common defense for people who
promote conspiracy theories but it's
actually a dangerous weaponization of
free speech because the idea behind I'm
just asking questions is I'm seeking
information
I'm not promoting anything false by
asking a question how could I it's just
a question I'm asking a question because
I seek information but that's of course
not the case when it comes to a lot of
these conspiracy theories the people who
are just asking questions are asking
questions as a way to promote false
baseless sometimes harmful ideas without
having to take the responsibility for
the consequences of floating those ideas
someone might say I'm just asking
questions have you ever considered that
the moon landing was faked why haven't
you considered it whatever and when you
look at the intent of that it implies
there's reason to support the conspiracy
theory when in fact there's overwhelming
evidence to show actually the moon
landing was real and the problem with
this type of rhetoric is that it lets
the false information spread without
being challenged because at the end of
the day what's wrong with asking a
question and it also creates a false
equivalency between here are the
established facts and here are just
these are questions and they're just as
valid well actually there are questions
with the intent to promote a conspiracy
theory and uh when someone says I'm just
asking questions we can evaluate their
intention why is it that they are asking
this question and not a different one
why is Comer asking remember he doesn't
have evidence for any of this stuff why
is he asking were there what what did he
say were there bio weapons versus were
there tootsie rolls right both would
just be questions no evidence for either
why is he asking one but not the other
well you have to go and look at his
intent and the intent of course is to
sew exactly this type of uh concern
about the Biden Administration we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P here's another voicemail about
my appearance on the Patrick Bet David
podcast
David is Allen from Jersey yeah I don't
know what the heck is going on with you
but you're on some weird PB and J
podcast and this right TV and Jay guy is
like Joe Rogan except
he's exactly like Joe Rogan except he
has hair okay and you're trying to tell
him how you were scamming people into
buying the the extra insurance at
Circuit City uh
and he doesn't want to talk about that I
mean
what the hell's going on with you David
I mean you're moving to Florida now
you're swimming with the dolphins you're
gonna move into the villages and with
Pat and well listen I'm not going to The
Villages but I have to tell you there is
something very appealing very appealing
about getting out of the cold for two to
three months out of the year maybe I'll
become a snowbird but if I did it's
gonna have to be Southern Florida I
don't see myself as a Jacksonville guy
um but uh as far as the pbd appearance
we'll be publishing the whole thing to
our YouTube channel very soon and I look
forward to getting more great feedback
about it pbd is Joe Rogan with hair
though is an interesting one we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpathman.com don't miss it I will
see you then
foreign